you have a sign oh you want a 20-second
hug
yeah i have to keep talking while we do
it though what is your name
marissa hi you're a fan of the podcast
okay let's do it on the stage
we'll do it on the stage
do you have a camera
you can take a picture
we talk about on the podcast this this
seems like something that i just do to
pander uh
no not yet this this is bonus
this is bonus
oh okay chris will take a photo so a
20-second hug biologically speaking is
the most beneficial hug for both people
in the hog because it start accuse
things in your brain that are associated
with trust
love and safety
so you have to count don't clap till the
end is we're blowing well don't see are
you what am i doing
i'm not counting i'm not counting
someone's counting someone's like we
gotta start the show seven you got it
what a perfect way to start the show
thank you
you